e
campagne qui repart.
Raphaë
- Des heures d'échanges avect
à qui on a reproché de ne pas
être suffisamment allé
sur le terrain.
- M. Macron, M. Macron,
M. Macron!
le 24 avril, l'entourage
d'Emmanuel Macron prévoitprévoit
multiplier les événements comme
celui-ci. Des arrêts un peu
partout au pays, e
Emmanuel Macron s'est arrêté
dans un ssemblement
national. Marine le Pen a obtenu
plus de 40 % dans cette petite
ville du
Mais c'est beaucoup aux
électeurs de gauche que le
président sortant tend la main.
EMMANUEL MACRON, c
La République en Marche
- Je suis venu expliquer
dans le projet que je porte,
en particulier pour lestravaills
retraités.
- À Denain, où Emmanuel Macronle
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a devancé
en obtenant près de 30 % des
voix. Le président cherche
à courtiser ces électeurs, lui
gauche pour vouloir faire passer
l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans.
- La retraite 65 ans, non, non!
- Devant les électeurs de cette
ville, l'une des plus pauvres
donc des mesures économiques
et sociales visant à augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat.
Si certains sont satisfaits des
gestes posés par le gouvernement
- Au niveau du pouvoir d'achat,
on a quand même e ont permi onts
pour l'instant de pallier au
coût de la vie qui augmente,
comme les chèques énergie.
- La colère de nombreux
électeurs sont palpables.
débarquer dans une ville aussi
pauvre que Denain e
show comme ça. C'est ce qui m'a
fait venir à vélo de chez moi,ee
deuxième voiture tellement la
de plus en plus chère.
- Un mécontentement que cherche
justement à canaliser Marine
Le Pen, du Rassemblement
sur le terrain. La candidate
d'extrême-droite, qui travaille
depuis longtemps à adoucir
son image, veut rallier les
électeurs en mettant notamment
MARINE LE PEN, candidate prés.,
Rassemblement National
- Je compte sur tous les
électeurs français. Voilà.
Je compte sur leur lucidité,
je compte sur leur capacité à
prendre conscience qu'on ne peut
pas continuer 5 andans
cette situation.
- Marine Emmanuel
Macron n'ont que deux semaines
pour convaincre les électeurs
orphelinés par
l'abstention. Dans une course
qui s'annonce serrée, ces appuis
pourraie
Ici Raphael Bouvier-Auclair,